[Música]
continúa desde el sur de méxico la nueva
caravana de emigrantes que pretende
llegar a eeuu las autoridades continúan
entregándole el permiso con el que
podrán avanzar por territorio mexicano
protestas en ecuador el principal
movimiento indígena del país inició una
serie de manifestaciones que han
provocado el bloqueo de carreteras para
exigir una disminución en los precios
del combustible
residente guillermo lasso advirtió
contra acciones vandálicas
el gobierno chileno anunció un plan para
iniciar la búsqueda de las más de 1000
personas que continúan desaparecidas
desde la dictadura de augusto pinochet
en esta edición hablamos con una de las
víctimas sobre la ruta que debería tomar
el ejecutivo
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en méxico tras el
salvoconducto otorgado por el gobierno
los migrantes retoman su camino desde
territorio mexicano hacia la frontera
estadounidense con la ilusión de cruzar
y encontrar nuevas oportunidades pero
aún la travesía no termina y pueden
hallarse con la posible negativa de las
autoridades de eeuu para entrar a este
país
con la esperanza de llegar a eeuu van
atravesando méxico estos migrantes en su
mayoría venezolanos
vamos ya avanzando mucho vamos a
monterrey pero ten en cuenta dos unidos
logramos pasar
tengo fe que pasar en conjunto con mis
compañeros
y agradeció con ello también estoy me
ayudaron mucho mucho la travesía que ha
durado meses está a punto de acabar el
gobierno mexicano les dio la posibilidad
de obtener un salvoconducto por 30 días
para estar en el país el instituto
nacional de migración mexicano se ha
visto rebasado debido a la cantidad de
solicitudes los que han logrado obtener
lo aprovecharon para salir de tapachula
ciudad fronteriza con guatemala que se
ha convertido en un cuello de botella
para decenas de miles de indocumentados
que ingresan desde centroamérica aquí en
méxico puede como el único momento en el
que dije bueno en el que me pregunte si
todo esto valdría la pena
estoy ahorita estoy muy motivado me toca
dormir en la calle con una herida
abierta en el pie eso me preocupa mucho
de verdad
pero
en favor de dios los migrantes
venezolanos esperan recibir un trato
especial de eeuu aunque algunas medidas
que ha anunciado el gobierno de joe
biden a su favor solo benefician a
quienes ya se encuentran en territorio
estadounidense
las caravanas de emigrantes han
recorrido méxico desde 2018 y 2019 desde
entonces el país ha reforzado sus
controles en la frontera sur en 2021
fueron detenidos más de 307 mil
migrantes
en cuba las autoridades empezaron a
sancionar a los cientos de manifestantes
que participaron de las protestas del 11
de julio del año pasado de un total de
381 personas
297 fueron condenadas a entre 5 y 25
años de prisión
señaladas de sedición sabotaje robo con
fuerza y desorden público mientras que
el resto recibió penalidades cientos de
personas más esperan sentencias o se
encuentran apelando a las sanciones
y este lunes los indígenas ecuatorianos
protagonizaron manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de guillermo lasso debido al
empeoramiento de su calidad de vida con
problemas como el desempleo o la subida
del precio del combustible y aunque las
protestas se han desarrollado sin
mayores incidentes el presidente
advirtió que responder a acciones
vandálicas
con hogueras y barricadas los
ecuatorianos indígenas encabezados por
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas volvieron a manifestarse
pacíficamente para exigir al gobierno de
guillermo las mejores condiciones de
vida la movilización es de carácter
nacional la movilización tiene de
carácter territorial y la movilización
tiene de carácter indefinida si es que
el día de hoy el presidente de la
república da respuestas entonces el día
de hoy levantaremos si el presidente de
la república no da respuestas a ninguno
de los puntos entonces nos mantenemos de
manera indefinida los motivos de las
movilizaciones vienen de largo con un
índice de pobreza del 27 7% y la
economía recuperándose de la pandemia
los orígenes ecuatorianos acusan el
desempleo y la caída de los precios de
los alimentos básicos y comercializan
como la papa o la cebolla controlados
por el gobierno
un descontento agravado por la subida
del precio del combustible que casi se
ha duplicado respecto a 2020 estamos en
verdad literalmente muriendo nos de
hambre con el alza de los combustibles
pues automáticamente alzó todos los los
productos de primera necesidad desde el
gobierno el presidente guillermo lasso
advirtió que no permitirá bloqueos en
quito en la amazonía donde también hay
protestas quienes intenten estas
acciones vandálicas deben saber que
tomaremos todas las medidas necesarias y
aplicaremos las leyes con todo el rigor
posible las manifestaciones indígenas ya
han logrado derrocar a tres presidentes
y han presionado a muchos gobiernos en
2019 marcharon en contra del gobierno de
lenin moreno unas protestas que se
saldaron con al menos 11 muertos y sin
un acuerdo con el gobierno a la vista la
situación podría repetirse
en chile a 50 años del golpe militar que
derrocó al ex presidente salvador
allende y marcó el inicio de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet que se
extendió por 17 años el gobierno de
gabriel boric se anunció un plan que
contempla la búsqueda de las más de 1000
personas que siguen desaparecidas tras
este sangriento episodio de la historia
chilena
previamente hablamos con patricia
heredia hija de juan heredia
detenido-desaparecido en chile durante
la dictadura de pinochet quien nos contó
cuál debería ser el punto de partida de
este plan
bastida está en que los casos de los
detenidos desaparecidos y ejecutados
tanto es identificado claramente
claramente se sabe que fueron la gente
del estado la mayoría de nosotros
conoce a aquellos que fueron a detener
torturar asesinar ocultar hacer
desaparecer a nuestros familiares es el
caso de mi familia que nos conocemos
absolutamente
yo creo que aquí lo que falta en
realidad es que la fuerza armada diga la
verdad ellos lo saben ellos lo tienen
simplemente nos lo han dado a conocer
que no es lo mismo pero para eso se
requiere de una buena voluntad de parte
de las fuerzas militares
a mi juicio por toda la experiencia
vivida
es un poco compleja
y colombia elegirá presidente el próximo
domingo 19 de junio y la migración
aunque no ha sido un tema fundamental en
la campaña sigue siendo polémico entre
la sociedad colombiana 1,8 millones de
venezolanos ahora viven en el país sin
embargo la población migrante se
enfrenta a expresiones xenofóbicas que
suelen aumentar en contextos políticos
complejos como estos comicios
amor leyó
cuatro años han pasado desde que jean
carlos y su familia llegaron a colombia
desde venezuela pero ese tiempo no acabó
con la discriminación que los rodea
especialmente a sus hijos en el primer
grado que estuve estudiando unos niños
le clavaron una punta de la piel en la
pierna verdad y entonces
cuando fuimos a reclamar la profesora
dice que nosotros no tenemos derecho a
reclamar porque porque somo venezolana
cruzaron una extensa frontera para
toparse con otro tipo de barreras unas
que se dirigen sobre la xenofobia que
crecen ante las elecciones
presidenciales todas votaciones en
cualquier país afecta directamente a
toda la población que esté y sobre todo
más la población migrante nosotros
ahorita estamos en una zozobra porque no
sabemos qué es lo que va a ocurrir con
nosotros
son estos momentos de tensión política
que le dan sentido al barómetro de
xenofobia alejandro un joven venezolano
es codirector de la plataforma que
monitorea los discursos alrededor de la
población migrante los comicios
presidenciales encienden sus alarmas
analizamos también todas las
declaraciones que han dado los distintos
candidatos a la presidencia y candidatas
la mayoría ha sido una gran ausente esto
es preocupante porque finalmente unas
políticas más importantes que estuvo el
gobierno de bush que una de las pocas
que se felicitó a nivel nacional
internacional ha sido la integración de
a personas migrantes venezolanas una
política migratoria primera que no hace
eco en la sociedad colombiana una
encuesta de invamer muestra que 60% de
la población no está de acuerdo con que
el gobierno acoge a los migrantes
venezolanos lo que hemos visto es que
cuando se incrementan los niveles de
xenofobia hay mayor posibilidad de
vulneración a los derechos de las
personas migrantes
en medio del panorama gris sobresalen
algunos destellos
como los platos de comida que entrega my
ir a una voluntaria venezolana en este
comedor comunitario a través de este
programa hemos logrado
bajar la discriminación e incluso
tenemos un comedor que es
mayor parte para migrantes venezolanos
entonces ha sido una manera también de
integrarlos a la comunidad a la sociedad
donde en este momento están haciendo
vida pero estas iniciativas no son
suficientes en 2021 más de 60.000
hogares migrantes no tenían acceso a la
salud y más de 200.000 vivían en acción
a miento crítico unos pendientes a los
que se enfrentará quien llegue al
palacio de nariño
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]